we're just beginning the investigation
into what gave rise to the january 6th
attack on the u.s capitol but what we're
learning is that
this was no fluke this was planned in
advance from everywhere from instagram
to facebook to the dark web
and this wasn't just idol chatter from
some rando on a conspiracy theory
forum though they certainly participated
as well no a lot of these people were
middle class americans who just
contracted brain worms from
newsmax oan fox news and sometimes even
their relatives on facebook
and while it's certainly possible that
some of these people never thought that
it would get out of hand the way it did
a lot of these people planned it ahead
of time and what unifies
all these people together is that they
are all going to face
incredibly harsh criminal sentences for
some of the things that they perpetrated
whether they
intended to do it or not and while some
of the perpetrators flew in on a private
jet and are now asking for a
presidential pardon
let's talk about what crimes all of
these rioters and their leaders
might be charged with
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a criminal defense lawyer because a lot
of these rioters are going to need one
now before i dive into the litany of
crimes that these rioters might face
there are two general considerations
that i think are particularly
interesting here
the first is that a lot of people have
been surprised at the relatively light
charges that have been levied so far
so far hundreds have been charged and
probably hundreds more will be charged
as well
but people have been surprised at the
types of crimes that they've been
charged with
many face lesser charges such as
unlawful entry disorderly conduct and
defacing public property
and only a few have been accused of the
more serious crimes like felony
violations of the right act and we're
going to talk about that in just a
second
but one thing that is overlooked here is
that
these might not be the final charges
it's pretty common for authorities to
make arrests based
on readily proven charges in this case
such as trespassing and then weeks later
prosecutors can seek
a grand jury indictment on more serious
charges
and a lot of this has to do with the way
that federal courts operate because in
order to charge
someone with a felony you have to go
before a grand jury a grand jury
although it has a very grand title is
really just a group of individuals
that act as a check on prosecutorial
power even before things
go to trial generally speaking a
district attorney or in this case a u.s
attorney would have to go before a grand
jury and say
here's the probable cause for me to
indict a criminal
and only after the grand jury signs off
on that particular proceeding can you
then
indict someone for a felony charge one
way around that is a u.s attorney can
swear an affidavit of probable cause to
a magistrate judge and get what's called
a criminal complaint to
start the proceedings and avoid having
to convene a grand jury you basically
start the process by complaint and you
can get a complaint for either a
misdemeanor charge or a felony but the
difference is that while
you can charge a misdemeanor without
ever going to a grand jury generally for
a felony
you have to go in front of a grand jury
within
30 days of getting that criminal
complaint
now there are two main reasons why you
might want to use the complaint process
and might explain some of the things
that we're seeing with respect to the
writers
the first is that some jurisdictions
don't actually have a grand jury
convened right now
because of covid related reasons and the
other is that you might use a criminal
complaint to
get someone into the court system to get
them under the court's supervision
so that you can go back and charge more
serious things later
so with the initial charges filed a
federal prosecutor might go before a
grand jury later and then seek
significantly more serious crimes
and even then once there is a formal
indictment you can always convene a
grand jury to get a superseding
indictment and charge them with even
more
serious crimes so if you are a capital
rioter
and you think you're off relatively
scot-free because you were just charged
with misdemeanor trespass
more serious charges may definitely be
on the way
now the other issue that i think is
overarching here is
the issue of conspiracy because a lot of
these people coordinated with each other
both
before they attacked and laid siege to
the capitol and then
even while they were in the midst of it
certain people coordinated with each
other
there is actually a federal conspiracy
statute but for the most part that's an
add-on to
other and different crimes people have
to agree
to some sort of crime and there has to
be a meeting of the minds but you can't
conspire to do something not illegal you
can't conspire with your friends to go
have dinner together that's
not a crime i guess unless you're
talking about covet restrictions but
let's put that aside
you cannot conspire to do something
that's not a crime but the
benefit of charging someone with
conspiracy from a federal prosecutor's
perspective is that
you don't actually have to complete the
crime to be guilty you just have to take
one overt act in furtherance of that
conspiracy or in furtherance of that
ultimate
criminal end so if there are
circumstances that give rise to an
agreement a meeting of the mind where
people take at least one step
toward it then effectively all of the
people who are participating in the
conspiracy
can face penalties that are basically
the same as
the initial underlying crime itself so
we're just about to talk about all the
different crimes that all these people
might have committed but
on top of that if any particular person
regardless of
what individual crimes they might have
committed themselves if they agreed to
participate
in a conspiracy to commit one of these
crimes they could be
guilty of that conspiracy as well but
with that understanding let's dive into
the actual crimes that the
capital rioters might be facing now of
course there were a lot of people there
doing a lot of illegal things so not
everyone
is likely to have committed one of these
crimes but this is
sort of a smattering of the things that
they're likely to to face
and the first is the word that you've
probably been hearing a lot these days
and that is
sedition in particular a seditious
conspiracy found in 18 usc
section 2384 which states that if two or
more persons conspire to overthrow put
down or destroy by force the government
of the united states or to levy war
against them or to oppose by force
the authority thereof or by force to
prevent hinder or delay the execution of
any law
or by force to seize take or possess any
property of the united states
now we have covered the law of sedition
and treason many times on this channel
and at this point
you're probably sick of hearing me talk
about how it's not sedition it's
never sedition that these people are
guilty of well
congratulations because this is not the
same case this is
probably a slam dunk for many of the
riders
they probably committed sedition because
lots and lots of people
stormed the capital clearly used force
specifically they tried to prevent
congress from certifying the election
and certifying that joe biden is the
president of the united states
if that's not using force to oppose a
law of the united states i'm not sure i
know what is
so despite the fact that it's never
sedition here
it's probably sedition and by the way
because the events of january were so
incredibly preposterous that's the the
legal term
i've noticed a ton of new people coming
to the channel but only a small number
are actually subscribed so
if you enjoy this legal analysis and
want to see me lose my mind over the
next thing i'll have to explain as a
lawyer
make sure you subscribe but there's
actually an interesting coda to this
whole sedition conspiracy thing which is
that
in september of 2020 the doj created a
memo which actually recommended
charging protesters with section 2384
the only thing is that those protesters
were the blm protesters over the summer
the memo was authorized by former
attorney general bill barr and signed by
now acting attorney general jeffrey
rosen
and they intended it to be used against
black lives matter protesters and antifa
and the memo goes on to recommend
charging protesters with violations of
18 usc 1361 damage to federal property
18 usc 844 use of fire or explosives
18 usc 231a civil disorder 18 usc
2101 a riots 18 usc 875 interstate
communications
18 usc 1369 damage to veterans monuments
and 18 usc 1952 interstate foreign
travel or transportation in aid of
racketeering enterprises
and no i am not going to cover rico in
this video
but this memo is a really interesting
lesson that all of these things that are
on the books
can be charged in circumstances that you
may or may not agree with and while a
lot of people want to throw the book
at the capitol riders perhaps they might
not feel as strongly about throwing the
book
at the protesters over the summer who
supported blm
so that takes us to the other buzz word
that you've probably been hearing a lot
and that
is insurrection now that's covered in 18
usc 2383 rebellion or
insurrection and section 2383 makes
rebellion against the united states a
crime
specifically whoever incites sets on
foot assists or engages in any rebellion
or insurrection against the authority of
the united states or the laws thereof
or gives aid or comfort there too shall
be fined under this title or imprisoned
not more than 10 years or both and shall
be incapable of holding office under the
united states
as i've covered before there are a whole
bunch of other criminal laws that apply
here that are probably a better fit than
rebellion this sort of rebellion
insurrection we might be splitting hairs
they're not necessarily trying to
overthrow the government they're just
trying to
change the government from their
perspective
so arguably i don't think this fits
unless they did something really stupid
like claiming it was a revolution
and why did you want to go in we're
storming
the capital it's a revolution come
on but arguably the same
arguments apply to 18 usc 2385 which is
advocating the overthrow of the
government
though a lot of people did some
incredibly stupid things that
might actually toe the line on these
ones for example the infamous racist
known as baked alaska whose real name is
tim giannay
live streamed himself breaking into the
capitol building and called for all the
congress members to be hung
in the middle of the riot so who knows
at this point it depends on
how aggressive the federal prosecutors
want to be and
how determined they are to get a
conviction in these different cases
but that takes us to another really
interesting federal statute which is the
anti-riot act in 18 usc 2101
now the anti-riot act requires that a
defendant travel in interstate commerce
or use its facilities with the intent to
follow one of the objectives listed in
one through four
each with a riot as the objective now if
this crime
sounds familiar it's probably because
this was the central law at issue in the
trial of the chicago seven which i just
did a video on a few weeks ago
in that case several defendants were
charged with traveling to chicago to
start a riot
count one of the indictment against them
claimed that they conspired not only to
travel in and use the facilities of
interstate commerce
with the intent to incite organize and
promote and encourage a riot
but also to participate in and carry on
a riot to commit acts of violence and
further into the riot
and to aid and abet persons in such
activities
but at the same time this goes down as
one of the black marks of federal
prosecutions because
people largely perceive this trial of
the chicago 7 as being a show trial that
was meant to
punish the people who participated in
protests and punish them for their free
exercise of speech
and that takes us to a whole raft of the
less sexy crimes but
ones that are probably going to be
complete slam dunks like the
weapons charges that are found in 40 usc
section
5104 which are oddly specifically
tailored to this particular situation
which says that you cannot possess
firearms and other dangerous weapons in
congress and that you may not knowingly
with force and violence
enter or remain on the floor of either
house of congress
that really seems like it applies to
people who entered the
houses of congress and then there's
things like assault on federal officers
in 18 usc 1114 that
makes it a crime to kill or attempt to
kill any officer or employee of the
united states
or illegally possessing a dangerous
firearm on any federal facility in 18
usc 930 and then of course it should
surprise
no one that there's a whole bunch of
laws that prevent the destruction of
federal property
and then of course there is perhaps the
most on the nose law in all of this is
18 usc 351 congressional cabinet and
supreme court assassination kidnapping
and assault
which it should surprise no one makes it
a crime to assassinate kidnap or assault
members of congress the cabinet or the
supreme court
it's also illegal to attempt to do these
things so
even if you entered congress with the
intent to
hurt a member of congress you looked
around and you couldn't find a member of
congress you're still probably guilty of
the attempt
to do it so as you can imagine that's
real bad news for the guy that brought
flexcuff zip ties into congress even
though he actually wasn't able to hold
any particular member of congress
hostage
and then finally the last category of
crimes that are likely under these
circumstances depending on how
aggressive federal prosecutors want to
be
are the whole swath of anti-terrorism
laws
that exist it's entirely possible that
federal prosecutors will look at this
as a terrorist incident this was a whole
bunch of people
using force and firearms and explosives
and
trying to undermine the government and
achieve their political ends in an
anti-democratic way
in direct contravention of the actual
functioning u.s democracy
it's entirely possible this qualifies as
terrorism
and i would not be surprised if federal
prosecutors took that tact
but the bottom line is that this is all
incredibly serious and these people can
be charged with any number of these
crimes and
if they are indicted then they'll need
to call a really good lawyer and the
best way to make that call is with ting
mobile
i personally switched to ting mobile why
well because
of this yes that is a real bill that i
actually got
but ting mobile has three brand new
plans that make sure that that never
happens you can get talk and text for
only ten dollars a month data plans
starting at fifteen dollars a month and
unlimited for everything
for forty five dollars per month and
switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and use pretty much any phone at
this point
and the service is great too because
team partners with several massive
networks in the u.s
very possibly the exact same carrier
that you're using right now but at a
huge discount
now contractually i can't tell you which
ones in particular because i always
respect contracts but if you've ever
gotten a bill like mine
your service probably won't change so
whether you use
2 gigabytes or 20 gigabytes a month
there's a perfect ting plan for you
in the past i've been on the phone with
my cell phone carrier for hours and
hours for even
minor things but with ting you can call
them up and a human will pick up right
away or if that's not your thing you can
message them on the internet even talk
to them through discord and of course if
you're around wi-fi
all the time like you're working from
home then you have the flexibility to
save
even more money because ting's flex plan
gives you the option to just pay for
what you use it's a smarter cheaper
version of the same plan that they've
always had
now they just have the option of
unlimited versions as well so if you
want unlimited data
absolutely go crazy so if you go to
legaleagle.ting.com or click on the link
in the description you can use your last
bill to compare just how much you would
save
and legal eagles will also get a 25
service credit that could cover
months of service so just click on the
link in the description and give it a
try
plus clicking on that link really helps
out this channel so do you agree with my
analysis
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews where
i talk about
all the crazy stuff that has happened in
the trump administration and
out of the executive branch so click on
this playlist and i'll see you
in court